we all have a favorite or at least a
memorable jerry springer moment now some
we can talk about and others well we can
only shake our head for 25 years
jerry has showcased some of the craziest
parts of humanity and you know what
people love it anybody can be a talk
show vote you do three things to be a
talk show host you have to be able to
say you did what
come on out we'll be right back if you
can do those three lines you've got a
career that's the first secret to
Jerry's success make it look easy we've
spent a lot of time with Springer during
his 25 years on the air the host hasn't
changed much but his show sure has
listen to Jerry described it in his
first et interview back in 1994 our talk
show tends to deal more with news
subjects or political subjects because
of my background scratch the politics
Springer was all about baby daddy fights
when we went behind the scenes with him
in 1998
Jerry carried a bat and evolved into the
kind of ringleader that made him a
pop-culture icon I mean the day I
figured out while we're on to something
there were two cultural moments that
impacted me and I think one was being on
The Simpsons
how did it feel to learn your baby was
fathered by a drooling space octopus it
made me angry Jerry and the other was
being on the cover of Rolling Stone
that's was honestly the first time I
noticed that oh my gosh people are
really noticing it
but none of that goes to his head that
Springer second secret admit the
stupidity our show is a circus period it
has no redeeming social value the show
is 25 Springer he's almost 73 but don't
mention retirement Jerry's third secret
worked to stay young I just do it
because it's fun to do and I'm not that
good at golf I mean I think I'd go crazy
I'm always afraid not to be working it's
psychological I'm sure if I
ever have nightmares about something
it's about not having a job which is
crazy I know 25 years yeah I'll see you
at the 50th 25 years from now I think I
won't be talkative
but you can if you just yell loudly
Jerry what do you think say something I
know what I'm gonna put on my tombstone
what's it gonna say I won't be right
back you know at its high point in 1998
the Springer Show actually had more
viewers than the oakland winfrey show
that was also the year of his infamous
band episode i married a force